you can see here the question is
casually different terms what would you
expect to pay versus how much is my bank
account going to be work okay but you
can see it's much the same kind of idea
right there's a present price that's
going to be the same as the principal
you've got an inflation rate % which is
go to function just the same as the
interest rate % and then lastly the
number of is assumed I'm just exporting
exactly so let's have a go this um what
would you expect to pay so i'm going to
call this expected value right as I've
said before you should always use words
to describe what it is you're talking
about some not just numbers flying
around but you demonstrate you
understand what the numbers mean and
then from there I'm going to launch
straight into the same way that I did
compound interest in that there's an
initial value that's where I started
with one plus now what rate is a gory
out in this case 3-pointer yourself read
which I'm going to write as a decimal
like so very good there's my 1 plus R
and how long am i there for done this
okay so this is just the same as now see
there's a thing which you didn't mention
interest inflation with the same way
appreciation which is when I've got like
an antique and as I wait you know I want
to be examples they have a look at is
like don bradman's first bat or
something like that that's precious
right that's a really really valuable
thing yes to part of Australian history
so if you have that it's going to
increase in value but it's going to
increase on the same principle that
everything else does oh you're a course
going to reach the caffeine or sumthin
got another for me already 270 is that
it so there's a few more decimal places
but I've got around to the news
on time right question I have enough to
what something wow that's a classic yeah
see now so then the problem then becomes
commodity supply because there aren't
quite a few of those you master sort of
circulation yeah okay so here's a tip of
one okay here's example to just very
simply one of the remember i said to you
even though the mass is the same
inflation interests are quite different
ideas and one of the things is different
about them is that pretty much every
year your inflation rate can change
quite dramatically you'll notice these
numbers are always around if they're
realistic there was around this number
you remember state governments actually
it's in their interest to print more
money and make the economy have
inflation right generally it's agreed by
economist at three percent is a good way
it's just enough for people like all I
better spend money but it's not so much
that it destabilizes your economy
because it makes people sort of freaked
out when they like yet this money this
locker be worth anything tomorrow right
go look up if you want go look at this
and in particular um the example you can
think of is these guys does anyone know
why this year is important what was the
biggest thing to happen in this year the
world the second world war in terred
does anyone know anything special about
these guys in the second world war
particularly who are they allied with
yeah the people who lost the war okay
now when you have a look at these guys
go look up Jim
Oh get out Eliza are other safety the
now not annual not monthly not weekly
their daily in free inflation rate we're
over two hundred percent for hungry
following the war and just think about
that right that's like I've got my five
dollars okay and you can you can buy
like what do you buy it for five dollars
you can buy you my chicken value of this
the next day you can oh my heart that
boat you're like so what what are people
going to do in that environment to their
march like it's like what happens is so
bad the government stopped collecting
taxes because if they delayed a day in
the collection their taxes it was worth
noting the next day that's how poor the
support so you can see you know what
these numbers to be too big just in the
sweet spot and apparently three percent
is the sweet spot how are we going to
work this out I start with this theater
to get the costs 30 bucks by the way boy
have been foot used to be six dollars on
a Tuesday up your watch movies it's very
sad now okay do I suppose that's true
not just like a room oh so I'm gonna say
the expected value the expected value
again it's gonna start at a particular
value so I'm gonna begin with that but
here's what becomes different when we do
when we use i should say the compound
interest formula right i got 1 plus r to
the n that end signifies just do it
repeatedly right so if i were to do it
in long form if i would have write it
out properly it would just look like
this do you agree that this is
equivalent to what you read before I've
cubed it I just done it three times now
what's different in this question is
that every year you're not getting the
same rate every year it changes from
your year which it doesn't reality right
so I'm going to do it one two three
but each time it's changed i will change
the rate okay so the first year has what
what inflation rate i'll actually just
hold on it's over here I'm just let me
see she's special 0.002 a what's the
next year 35 and 50 years okay so at
that point there right again should I
understand what's going on calculate go
ahead okay so someone really
Alicia's not like at your audi like
three dollars 34 okay so I got a price
thank you so we only ran that yeah UK
with that okay so you can see again and
this is why I didn't well underperform
right the mathematics of it is not
different for what you've met before but
the idea underneath it is actually quite
different is worth having a look at